meeting which we have of the legislative
oversight committee for improvement and
assessment of our our program here in uh
education um I want to uh just reinforce
what we're we're doing today uh in the
calendar it's noted that this is a
meeting specifically for the Improvement
and assessment oversight uh committee
which we have which is comprised of
folks from the Senate and in the house
um we also have been directed by both
leadership on the minority side and the
majority side of the house to have a
committee in each policy committee a
subcommittee which reviews proposed
rules and makes recommendations to our
Jael car committee and so those folks
and we we kind of duplicate ourselves on
this committee that we're we're on both
so we will be doing both tasks at the
same time here and so we do have an
agenda for today I have
uh one copy right here but I also have
several other copies it's a very simple
agenda in terms of the first portion we
have three or four components here the
first component is what are the duties
legislative oversight committee and the
responsibilities of this committee and
the second uh part is dealing with the
proposed Ed 306 administrative rules for
education and we have a letter which I
wrote to the commissioner and the
commissioner has willingly and happily
come forward to the committee to present
where we are on those rules as of this
point in the process and that's part of
the presentation he will be doing
following that there will be a a portion
of her time used for uh question answers
uh between the commissioner and members
on this committee right here on this
panel so with that I'd like to go ahead
it is 10:00 I remind everybody this is
being streamed and so um we have the
mic's here if somebody can't hear us
please let us know and I'd like to go
ahead and looking at the first portion
where the duties of the legislative
oversight Committee in the previous year
we added on to the legislative oversight
committee a responsibility to review and
make recommendations relating to the
academic standards under consideration
by the State Board of Education pursuant
to RSA 193
E28 um that's the academic standards the
minimum standards for public school
approval are a total responsibility
they're approved by the State Board of
Education this committee has
responsibilities to look at academic
standards and as we look at it we also
look at uh part our statutes on 193e
where there is our 13 criteria for the
substitute criteria for an adequate
education which are dealing with the
academic standards and therefore a
responsibility of this panel right here
and when we're looking at this there's
certain SE within the the rules that are
being proposed there's a front side and
the back side I'm sure the commissioner
will speak to that the back side deals
with those subject areas the front side
deals with all those other areas within
what does the school have to achieve To
Be An approved public school so it goes
from facilities to Staffing to number of
credits you need to graduate from high
school Min and and then it also gets
into those subject areas with elements
within so without going any further on
that I'd like to jump down now I wrote a
letter to the
commissioner and in that letter
requested that uh we uh be have some
communication as where we are in that
process we recognize there's been an
extensive hearing process and we've had
an initial proposal we have a final
draft proposal uh and maybe we can be
updated as far as where we are on that
whole process and then have um uh the
presentation start with the commission
so I'd like to welcome commissioner
edbl uh Welcome to our committee here
Frank and um floor is yours good morning
and thank you for allowing me to come in
I brought all kinds of uh cheat notes
Here depending on what kinds of
questions you all have hopefully I can
um you know respond to those I wanted to
start my conversation I'm just going to
offer some comments and then I know
there's probably some questions and
queries yeah but I want to start my
comments
um you know in with uh RSA 193
E1 Roman numeral 2 which I think sets
kind of a a philosophy for um this Ru
making process and I want to be clear
when I uh share this information with
you that uh I represent the Department
of Education a state agency these rules
are the responsibility and owned by the
State Board of Education um I don't have
a vote on that committee so I'm happy to
update you in terms of where we are but
I just think it's that clear um but in
193 E1 Roman numeral 2 I'm going to
start about halfway through just to not
overly read to you um in this section
the state establishes minimum standards
for public school approval and academic
standards for inclusion in the delivery
of educational services at the local
level school districts then have
responsibility and flexibility in
implementing diverse educational
approaches to instruction and curriculum
tailor to meet the students needs and so
as we have approached this rule proposal
um we have tried to keep in mind the
Mandate from the legislature uh that
school districts have responsibility and
flexibility in implementing a diverse uh
array of educational approaches to
instruction and curriculum tailor to
meet students needs and we want to make
sure that this rule proposal does not uh
interrupt their ability to meet their
legislative obligation uh under
193e um so just to kind of talk to you
about the process as you describe we're
kind of in the middle of this it's been
a
three-year problem and as you point out
Rick uh we have bifurcated this rule
proposal into what we refer to as a
front half and a back half the front
half deal primarily with um how uh
schools operate right how you how you
functionally run the school and then the
back half dealing much more closely
associated with content uh I'm happy to
speak to both parts of that but the
front half is the part that is before uh
this committee and that is the the the
furthest along in that Ru making process
um it is uh sort of an interesting
couple of interesting facts for this
committee that they may not know um
there was an attempt in 2014 um by my
predecessor to update the 306s in
particular the back half um that was not
successful it's interesting I I have a a
copy of the the minimum standards that I
actually printed out before I even took
this job um to familiarize myself with
what was going on in there I'm on my
second um spine of duct tape that's how
much worn out they are but even in this
uh in this proposal they talk about here
are uh you know here are rules rules
that apply until July 1st 2015 and then
here's the rules that will apply from
July 1st 15 onward anticipating that
they would have been approved um sadly
uh that effort was unsuccessful uh I
want to share another piece of rules at
that time were reopt to the old correct
they just kept the old rules right so
nothing was nothing changed exactly I
remember that thoroughly oh do you okay
I was not part of it but I just thought
that was interesting um I also want to
read a couple of headlines that I think
might be telling for you so this is a
headline fur in New Hampshire on vote to
cut
standards um and reading from this
particular article it says the change
would free cities and towns to set their
own standards for maximum class size
Advocates say the change would give
local districts more flexibility arguing
this could lead to improve schools and
to tailoring School services to meet
Community needs similar to the um you
know what it says in the statute what is
interesting about these two articles uh
they are from The New York Times from
1992 and I read this and I was like oh
my goodness we're still having the same
conversations from 1992 and now um so
you can see that this is an effort that
has been ongoing and the conversations
have been taking place for decades uh
here in the state of New Hampshire and I
think I share that because um I mean
that's important everybody who is
working on this rule proposal has has
the same goal we want our students to
have the best opportunities to succeed
in life and uh that is what we are after
and so we are you know the all the
conversation that takes place around
this I think we need to stay focused on
the fact that we're all sitting here
sitting here and working to try and
benefit uh the students of and the
children of New Hampshire um the process
started out with a working group with
the national Center for Competency Based
learning um that working group included
superintendents principal School Board
teachers digital Equity project leaders
Business Leaders uh and other Educators
um and they got together initially and
were working on kind of some initial uh
an initial draft that they were working
on uh they held a number of listening
sessions uh across the state um as well
as as a group and a lot of virtual
sessions um they held working sessions
there was a working session in the fall
with 45 Educators um and then after that
Christine Downey held working uh uh
listening sessions with over 200
Educators around the state um whereas a
typical rule proposal has a single
public hearing uh this particular rule
proposal had three public hearings uh to
make sure that we created many
opportunities for people to weigh in on
this rule uh we also created an extended
uh public input period that lasted
through the end of April uh again to
afford everyone an opportunity to weigh
in in on this um and in spite of all of
this I I will say that there continues
to be uh a variety of uh inaccurate
information relative to the rule
proposal but I'm happy to respond to
questions about that um there are
because this is uh a a a process that's
in the middle like we're still this
process is still ongoing the board is
still working on this rule proposal um
so I have a document in front of me here
and I'm happy to share this with you but
again understand that it's a fluid
document and it includes a side by side
and the side by side um it includes uh
you know the initial what do we call it
the the current rule you know so
basically what's in currently in the
306s and then what we have is the
initial proposal which was adopted I
believe in February and then subsequent
to that initial adoption uh we had
meetings with uh you know ongoing
meetings because it wasn't like this was
the first time we had ongoing meetings
with the Nea and with the uh nhsaa some
Business Leaders um to work on to
further work on that initial proposal
and we reached agreement on a number of
additional changes um and then we
received feedback from Jael car and so
we've responded and are working on
responses to the Jael car comments as
well so just try to be really
transparent and keep track of these uh
this is the document that the board was
working on in their last working session
the board scheduled a separate working
session apart from their normal meeting
schedule uh for the sole purpose of
working on this uh so that anybody who
was interested could come and here uh
you know the deliberations of the board
in terms of wrestling through and
looking at the different aspects in the
different areas um I want to flag a
couple of uh you know changes to this
document that I think are excuse me just
for one second commissioner um we have
copies of the current 306s here great
the initial and the proposed but we
don't have a copy of that side by side
is that available so that the committee
can have that at the close of the
meeting today yes we will email that
over to you said that you'll have a copy
of that um and so there is not just to
be clear so there's not a final proposal
yet the board is still working on this
uh in that working session I got I think
we got through about page 67 or
something right like obviously this a
very substantive rule um and they intend
to take it up at this next meeting until
and and continue to work through the
rule proposal so there will likely be
additional changes that they adopt um
but I want flag a couple of areas for
you um so one of the substantive changes
that took place here was that we've
added a number of definitions um working
with the Nea NH hsaa uh to make sure
that we're providing Clarity throughout
this document um and everybody's on the
same page um it's interesting um there
was one uh term in the uh in The
Proposal we had created a definition but
then we never used the word uh and so
that and people were like well why
didn't you why did you take that out I'm
like well because we didn't actually use
it any place so we're trying to figure
out if there's a place where that needs
to be used but you know we so because
the intent here is not to create a
dictionary as much as it is to to
clarify terms that will be used in this
role proposal um another place that
there was some confusion um and
misunderstanding is uh in my draft is on
page 32 but it really is in
section 306 oh no that's
.11 306
6.12 um and here a couple of years ago
the
legislature uh homogenized the education
statutes with other statutes of
oplc uh to refer to Educators as
licensed Educators um and so that
resulted in us changing the term
certified to licensed and there were
individuals who saw the term certified
struck out and misunderstood that that
had been changed to license to just make
it consistent with the law so we heard a
lot of uh you know feedback from people
like why did you eliminate certified
Educators and we certainly haven't in
this proposal uh we just made use the
term licensed which is what is
consistent with statute so wanted to
flag that one for you if that's one
that's interesting to you um as well
there was uh in that in a in that
section
30615 um which is in the proposal 30
6.12 but uh so we talked about Educators
including art music health physical
education teach teachers in accordance
with the class size requirements and so
basically those were already included in
the class size so nobody's eliminating
the requirements for art and music and
health education teachers uh they are
already called out in the section on
30617 where that resides and so this was
a redundancy and it was just to
clarifying the language in here um and
then I want to talk are you willing to
rather than jump over to talk about
30617 yeah that's where I was going to
go next actually is the CL the class
size yes that was the next item and
again I'll answer anything that we want
okay so it's interesting so I I didn't
know this until maybe like last week
when I found those uh articles from 1992
that this conversation about class size
is one that's been going on for decades
um and really let me try to summarize
kind of the perspective of uh you know
the department and not necessarily board
and so I I make sure that that is clear
um although this is the proposal from
the board you know the the proposed rule
said the local School Board shall
establish student centered ratios that
promote student learning as appropriate
for each learning opportunity learning
level I mean there was a great deal of
concern that we're eliminating class
sizes and so I just philosophically I
would tell you that the board is not
fixed on something here we're really
trying to have a substantive
conversation around this specifically
because if you are designing instruction
the first question that you would ask
yourself would not be how many kids do I
put in a classroom the first question
you'd ask yourself is like what is the
content that I'm teaching you might then
ask yourself what is the pedagogical
approach that I'm going to be using the
next question you might ask yourself is
what are the characteristics of these
individual Learners and then you might
get to how many of them should I cohort
together in order to create an effective
instructional environment and I don't
think that there's really any um debate
that there's more that goes into uh you
know making this determination than just
coming up with a number
um and so the board was really uh trying
to come up with some language that would
capture the the process that we want
schools to go through in order to be
able to figure out what is the right
number of students to cohort in a class
because um if you have uh you I mean 24
if let's say 24 is a number you put 24
struggling second grade readers into
class that's too many right like that
cohort side is wrong but if you had ask
all those precursor questions you might
end up at a different place and so we're
trying to just make sure that that
happens um you know we did ask uh a
number of organizations for proposed
language nobody's actually come up with
the uh the magic bullet on that one in
terms of what it is um you know language
that is being discussed right now as a
local school board shall establish
student educator ratios that promote
student learning uh for each learning
opportunity and learning level based
upon school safety policies content
instructional method and characteristics
of Learners and then the local school
board shall adopt model class sizes that
shall be used solely for purposes of
estimating School District budgets um
and again this is proposed language
certainly the uh the board is open to
whatever that might look like um it's
interesting since 1992 when we had this
debate previously maybe we had it before
that I don't know we have not seen an
increase in the educational attainment
of the students right so we've held the
line but we've not seen an increase in
outcomes and uh from from our students
and so the question is is there
something that we can do here that helps
now understandably on the flip side of
this there is a fear among many
communities and we've heard this loud
and clear in the public comment that
what this will do is cause uh
irresponsible School boards
to pack 50 students into a classroom and
you know resulting in a degradation of
the quality of the education that those
students are receiving in fact that's
not what anybody's intention is trying
to do right like we're all trying to
make sure that we're creating better
opportunities for students um and so the
question is how do we is there a way to
structure this I mean maybe we just got
to go back to the 1992 just put a number
in there um but I might even argue and
I've heard argumented in the public
comment that by just limiting those
class sizes we're also not preparing
students for the future particularly in
a postsecondary so you have a student
who's never been in a classroom that's
greater than 24 or 30 kids kids or many
of these students you know are in
classes of 12 students and all of a
sudden they find themselves in some
post-secondary institution at Ohio State
or at UNH with 300 students in the
seminar class right and so um but we're
you know I I can tell you that this is
not a hard conversation for the board
they feel very comfortable that you know
if we just have to go back then to where
we were that's okay but they want to try
and make sure that we challenge
ourselves that we challenge a state to
uh have an
opportunity yeah I got I got one I I
just have a couple of more points I was
going to flag for you and I'll take
questions are you're still in this
section yep okay why you go continue
with the section you're on which is
30617 okay and if there's anything
because there are questions from us okay
do you want to do let me go you want to
get through all my highlights for you or
you want to stop at each one I can stop
here if you want let's stop right here
while we're on it and had a little bit
of a discussion already 30617
it talks about uh learning levels first
grade levels it also uh has that that
current pupil teacher ratio is K through
2 25 to1 and then grades 3 through 12 30
to1 yes and with recommendation to be
less to
25 the concern that we had when we were
costing out the the education formula
budget and we're I'm sliding into
dollars and cents you are yeah and and
we had suggested that it be K through
three at 20 to1 and then um grades four
on upwards at that 25 one I believe
that's what we had within our recommend
it didn't fly anywhere but as the State
Board taking a a a real significant look
at this we realized that 30 to1 in an
Elementary classroom is is pretty tough
and it's if you're going to relate the
dollars ability to pay these people
that's they're
connected so the question is you know is
the state board really taking a good
look with because we are seriously
looking at ourselves yeah so I mean I I
think it's it's pretty obvious that the
State Board is pretty serious about this
even with the proposal they're saying
like look we have to ask the right
question 30 first graders or second
graders is too many kids in a classroom
even 25 might be too much you know a CO
if you have struggling readers then that
then 10 might be too many right like so
what we're trying to say is
is there a way to ask more to to to
write this rule in a way that provides
you know as the statute says
responsibility and flexibility to that
loal local school district and come to
good outcomes and not create a
circumstance where an irresponsible
School Board does something stupid for
these kids right I mean I don't know
that that's going to happen nobody knows
that's going to happen but uh but you
know so we're trying we so I think we
agree on all these kind of constraining
factors and and they 100% are looking at
this I I guess my last and then I'll let
others High School can make the the
necessary changes they can load up a PE
class or some other classroom but an
Elementary classroom is a classroom
and everything's taught in that in those
four walls mostly and so you know I
think there's got to be a lot of
flexibility for K through a um that's my
two cents worth uh are there questions
here representative Cornell
I I think it's it's fine to say that
leaving it up to individual school
districts will take the responsible way
of doing it but when you come across a
school district that's struggling with
money with finances or even struggling
to find teachers they're going to double
up on the size of their classes because
they have no other choice to do it
unless it's in statute that they can't
and if we don't tell them that you can
only have so many kids in a class if
they're struggling and they can save
money by doing it they're going to do it
so I I think it needs to be in there the
the exact class size and and if they
want to make it smaller they can but I
don't think we should let them make it
bigger than what it could be yes and
we've heard that feedback and the board
has heard that feedback loud and clear
um but you can understand that what
we're really trying to say is how do we
have this conversation about setting the
right class size is what we're trying to
get to maybe we can't get there um and
so I appreciate all of that what you
said is all relevant feedback I mean the
only thing that doesn't help me is is
you know that poor uh secondary student
who goes off to University and finds
himself in a 300 person seminar that's
never really experienced anything so
maybe if there were opportunities in our
secondary environment to to get kids
some kinds of exposures like that too uh
because we we want our kids to be
successful in that post-secondary world
as well what follow up follow up we all
did that though I mean I I was in
classes of 20 25 in high school and I
went to un where sometimes I would have
500 600 and I'd be watching it on a
screen yeah and so what we know is so
when those students go to those post-se
environments they can do it well some do
it but actually what you'll find is that
that's one of the biggest areas where
they don't succeed right because of the
degree of transition I'm glad that you
did it I did it I'm sure many of you did
it but there are students who are not
successful in making that transition so
is there something we can do to help
them transition right do we have a study
that shows us how many have failed no I
just have anecdotal information and
feedback from my uh you know
post-secondary universities okay thank
you y the last part I I needed a
rationale why we're changing it from
grade to learning level we're going to
have different learning levels at every
grade um so there be the part of the
issue and we we're trying to drive
towards a competency based education so
how's that come into this mix yeah so I
think it it's just yet more conversation
about trying to move towards a
competency based system and I think that
this is a conversation that came out of
that original study committee when they
were looking at this and trying to say
like you know really you know we're when
we say grades which is it's vernacula
that we're all so familiar with right uh
because it's been around for a very long
time but the reality is we want to focus
on students and students learning
Pathways and students are going to be at
different levels and so the question is
by using different vernacular does that
help us look at a student differently as
opposed to assuming because the student
is in fourth grade this is what they
need to be learning even if they haven't
mastered the third grade learning yet
right so we've moved this kid along but
we can say like okay so in math Billy's
on the fifth learning level in uh you
know reading language arts maybe he's at
the third learning level so we're really
trying to create a system that is
responsive to those students again not a
conversation not a not a change that I
think the board is fixated on uh as much
as just saying like how do we continue
to move forward our Competency Based
Learning System that recognizes that you
know students we don't want to dictate
to students what they should be learning
plus or minus 180 days to the day they
were born on which they had no say in um
essentially is what we're after here
thank you why we move on
here okay any further questions on that
portion I know there are but there it
they probably I have a question with the
the certified teacher as opposed to a
licensed person um is there an oursa
that that says it's okay to use a
licensed rather than certified teacher
in public schools there is in fact it
changed it the this you changed the um
the language in the law to talk not
about certified Educators anymore but
about licensed Educators so we just were
trying to make the law to make the rule
reflect what you did to the law several
years
ago so you've changed the law to
reference the requirements for licensed
Educators and so now the rule will
reflect the statute as well I can have
someone send over that statute that be
helpful so and follow up to that sort of
Frank um within statute it says grades
yep doesn't say learning level
so some may construe that by rule we're
changing statute which is counter you
know yeah which would be fly against
that argument no no question about it
and so we I don't think the board is
fixated on that so much as wanted to
make sure we have this conversation
about are we designing a system that's
respons to what the kid needs to learn
not based on what day they were born on
okay so given I mean and again this is
an opportunity for feedback I'm going to
bring all this feedback back to the
state board and uh you know just reflect
for them that they're not interested in
learning levels they're interested in my
my comment has nothing to do whether I
like or dislike something it it has to
do with consistency yeah no it has a
deal with legislative responsibility and
executive responsibility
the
executive takes law and goes moves
forward with a law it doesn't write law
and that's what we're sort of seeing and
maybe in some cases where you change the
definition of Competency when competency
is clearly established currently in law
yeah so that's where I'm driving here
and we ALS often times say grade levels
course program what have you and now
we're we're seeing a change coming from
the board rather than through the
legislative process so I guess what I
would how I would respond to that is um
you know this is a fairly substantive
you know like I've got like a 80 page
rule proposal that we've tried to hear
from a whole bunch of constituencies um
and I think to your point we see as an
agency our responsibility is to have
100% Fidelity to the law um so for
example again that Competency Based
definition was developed with all kinds
of input from all kinds of stakeholders
uh when we got the feedback from the um
from Jael car on like hey competen is
already defined in legislature I think
that the board is just going to adopt
the legislative definition because we
don't have authority to come up with our
own definition if you've already defined
a term thank you
y so let me uh just a couple of other
things I'll hit
so um let's see the next thing this was
a something that was pointed out and we
haven't resolved this completely yet um
but uh in in
section
306 hang that's a long one
30621 uh which is around high school
curiculum and credits and stuff like
that and then if you go to E we have a
list of uh you know courses that are uh
that the schools are required to offer
and um so this is another one that car
pointed out to us and and we think we
have to resolve this um but in
particular we've got something called
family and consumer science that's
enumerated there that the school is
required to offer that that is not in my
list that is allowable under 194 193 E2
right in other words so as I understand
the statute right if I look at that
statute I'm allowed to make rules
relative to the stuff that you guys have
given me but I don't get to go make up
and and require a school to offer a
course that you've not as a legislative
body already required and so again cons
family and consumer science has been in
there for decades right as a requirement
but uh as jel car pointed out they're
like hey family consumer science not is
not in the list so what is your
statutory authority to create rules
around that and we said good question
it's already been it's always been in
there so um one that we'll take back but
I don't know if the if the you know you
all want to you know wait in on that
figure give us an opportunity to do so
I'd like then to just jump when you talk
about family consumer science uh we have
as one of the 13 criteria personal
finance
literacy and that was just added in the
statute what a year or two ago um as
part of
adequacy and and I don't see any
reference to that and how how are we
going to deal with that and in the past
for example when we had like the fourth
year mathematics embedded the that
course in into the fourth year we took
statutory language and put that into
rule yeah um and and how we going to I
was talking to several people at
graduation kids and they're saying I
still don't know how to write a check
oops uh that's a real whoops and that's
what and that's what we heard from the
bankers Association too when we went
after personal finance literacy so how
do we integrate that into does it come
underneath what we just discussed yeah
so we if you see in the proposal we've
added number 18 personel finance and
financial literacy as a category um and
we have had conversation to say like
well do we have statutory Authority for
family and consumer science because that
incorporates to your point going right
to personal financial literacy there's a
little bit of personal finance in there
there is some economics that's
associated with that uh there might be
some social studies so does it fit into
those categories but otherwise we are
trying to determine if we have statutory
authority to even uh have that category
do you have statutory authority to fit
it into economics that's under social
studies those five components I believe
that we would if we wanted if we can
make the case that family and consumer
science is you know economics or
something like that but I don't think
the board has concluded on this yet but
that's what we're trying that's the
conversation we're having can we fit it
into these other categories in 193
E2 uh or not and if we can't we don't
know that we have statutory authority to
go forward if we do then our response to
jail car would be one that says well our
statutory Authority for family and
consumer science is that we believe that
this includes components of social
studies and personal finance and we just
have enumerated them as a separate line
item in this rule proposal but that's
the kind of thing that we're just
working through as we put the rule
together
so
um so the another section that we have
updated let me get this is going to be
on page 63
um is relative to so in the initial
proposal so uh in in the rule it
initially had like it said there were 43
courses that everybody was supposed to
offer and then it enumerated in each
course specifically how many classes in
each course right um let me just grab
that real quick
yeah so in other words like in arts
education you have to have three courses
in business education you have to have
three courses uh which by the way you
might have to try and figure out where
the business education fits in here as
well but um you know uh family and
consumer science you're required to
offer three courses as we've talked
about and so um when we did the initial
proposal we were not able to identify
you know where this 43 came up came from
you know what was magical about 43 like
why not 45 or why not 40 or why not 60
like what is the number and why three
art classes as opposed to four classes
and why three family consumer science
and not two of those and more of this um
and so initially we just said that they
were required to offer learning
opportunities um in working with the Nea
and and
hsaa uh you know there was a concern
that 43 was just a bridge too far like
if we pulled that out even though nobody
can really identify where it comes from
that that was just too substant of a
change so we basically said okay so you
have to offer 43 but across these areas
so they're going to still offer at least
43 classes but they're going to offer
them across these various domains but
again in offering school districts
flexibility and responsibility should we
be dictating how many family and
consumer courses you should have as
opposed to saying you got to offer at
least 43 classes and they got to be
across these domains you got to offer
something in each of these domains but
we're not going to tell you how to
distribute those courses across those
domains and so that's uh really kind of
where we are right now with that um so
that's an area that we've been working
on so you touched on the Arts and within
statute we don't call it just the arts
program it's arts program including
music and the visual arts correct so why
are we not using that definition within
the 306s rather than just calling it The
Arts good feedback we can absolutely do
that yeah art we can absolutely do that
and that way and that that in and of
itself I like that RI because that would
incorporate these other elements into it
so that it can't those other elements
that you're requiring in statute won't
be left out I think that's a great
recommendation and we might check some
of the other areas like Health it's
health and wellness y we should just our
language should just mirror that langage
we have in the criteria those 13 areas
is what we need to reflect English
language arts and reading yeah we just
use the the vernacular exactly yeah it's
a very helpful
meeting keep marching okay
um
68 so here's a a section that has
received very little public feedback
um which is other than so we had
initially established something called
graduation
expectations uh which is a little bit
like a portrait of a graduate um this is
in
section uh
30622 um and the only feedback that we
got really relative to those was that
they would they want them to not be
graduation expectations but graduation
requirements um and so the the that's
kind of the public comment um I was
surprised um that we were kind of
dictating those I mean I like all the
content uh that is in there um but I
thought it was um you know in so many
other areas where we're trying to be
careful not to overreach and uh and
require stuff this is it was a
requirement and that was feedback so I
just as I I'll leave that as a passing
thing um the next area that I wanted to
flag for you is in the table um and this
is the table see jul I didn't bring a
copy of this see if I can read this uh
it's a table
3061 and so in the initial proposal so
this is the required credits for
graduation and in the initial proposal
we had added additional required credits
and reduced the number of
electives um it initially it was six
electives and it reduced down to 2.5
electives um there was some concern I
think at the board level that uh you
know we have compulsory education these
students are required to go to high
school for four years but really that's
almost a full year of electives um and
so if these are the minimum standards of
what we really want to make sure these
kids get when they get out of high
school is that too many electives um but
then again in working with the Nea and
when nhsaa uh that was modified and so
now there's four electives um but some
of the additions that you'll see in here
uh included like a logic and rhetoric
course a Civ course where where are we
looking right now well with I found that
chart in the the original sorry um uh
let's see February 15 30621 sorry 30621
I'm sorry I didn't make a reference for
you I just referenced the table name
okay are you you at the chart required
program areas and courses or are you at
the chart which deals with the required
courses for high school
graduation 3 to 6.2 6. it might be two2
hang on let me go I'll go look at the
other this is the problem when you have
so many versions of these things going
yeah I I've got I've got one version of
this 36.2 one that's titled alternative
programs no it's not that
no page 37 of the initial proposal
the initial and it is
um if you're looking at the current rule
I believe it's in
30627 there's a table called 3062
required subjects and credits for high
school
graduation can and I'll give everybody a
minute to get there so 30627 in the
current
rule here 6.22
30622 and the proposed
rule yeah I'm just looking a different
version but I'm not
306.97 D2 which is required subjects and
credits for high school graduation in
the original in the current
rule do you have an extra copy of this
how many you got just
one that's so Mr chair the the initial
proposed that the commissioner's
reference is the February 15th 24
correct um and you said it's on
page 37 I believe the print out I've got
only has 33 Pages yeah okay so not to it
so yeah we took the uh the front side
stuff
there hey wa Julie will you go find it
for him and his Julie you can also look
at your document and find it for you so
you can also find it in the current
standard it's in the current standard I
found it under 27 in the currency yeah
that's where it is okay so that's the
one we we're looking at then okay okay
okay
yeah um and so essentially what we had
initially done is we reduced the number
of elective credits from 6 to
2.5 um the board has subsequently looked
at increasing that to four um but has
added additional course
requirements um you know a logic and
rhetoric a Civics and
civility um you know then and again some
of this is in response to HB 216 which
which was passed by the legislature that
required certain courses relative to
history so we have a history uh
government constitution of the
US um and then what was added was a half
a credit in statistics or data
analysis so when we you're adding in
logic and and rhetoric yeah we want kids
thinking we want them
communicating we when we put that into
adequacy yep we stated that
those areas of learning should be
integrated into all categories correct
so it's not one of the 13 It's down
below listed along with I believe
computer um and use and digital literacy
so why then are we making it a separate
course rather than integrating logic
thinking skills rhetoric able to
communicate with a little bit of logic y
uh
into language arts into mathematics into
social studies into Science Biology Etc
yeah so I think that the um the purpose
what the board is thinking and again I
don't know I can't get into their minds
completely but I think the thinking is
here that again these are the credits
that required for graduation so there's
now half a credit requirement for logic
and rhetoric um and it doesn't say that
that has to be offered as a separate
course but it does say whether it's
integrated or not integrated that you
have to have to demonstrate logic and
rhetoric and I think the point that the
board was after there is to make sure
that there's an emphasis right uh
sometimes when we focus on the
integration it gets diffused and maybe
is not emphasized enough and I think
that the board's intent there um and I
think that they believe they had
statutory Authority given its call out
in 193 E2 uh to require a half a credit
in that and not be disruptive to whether
or not it's integrated or not integrated
like so they're not specifying that it's
not
integrated we certainly won't don't want
to object to
logic and rhetoric being used in our
schools um we the intent was basically
to integrate that and I but I know when
we initially had computers in schools we
had to have a separate computer class
now we it's just you know spreadsheet is
part of everything it is
yeah
okay yes Reon Cornell so when you're
saying the board thought are you saying
the State Board of Education is the one
who's determining what these subjects
are that a student needs to graduate
from high school that's correct it's the
State Board of Education that sets the
rules okay and but what do they
were the State Board of Education is
deciding what classes students need to
graduate from high school they're
deciding what credits they need okay
thank you and so they're enumerating the
credits that are required for
graduation which is that's the system
that we've always had and then they're
trying to do that in Fidelity to the
statutes that you all have
passed so by putting these in the
equivalent required for graduation was
was 20 credits correct it's still 20
credits have not changed that okay just
have taken the six electives down to
four electives and added you know a half
a credit in mathematics specific to uh
you know statistics um you know half at
least a half ACC Credit in statistics
and data analysis I think again the
board's perception is that that's a very
gerine uh thing for kids to know to be
able to look at data and statistics and
understand understand that um they've
added uh you know half Credit in logic
and rhetoric um and then I believe
they've got a half a credit in uh it's
called Civics and civility
so by doing this where rather than
integrating are we cutting back on uh
the Arts are we cutting back on those
subjects which a student would truly
would benefit later in life I think this
is some of the feedback that we got when
we went from Two and a Half elective
credits to four elective credits some of
the feedback that we got from the Nea
from the nhsaa from some Educators were
like uh two things one is um you know
that that to your point there may be
students who are more focused in some of
these years and they want an opportunity
to get more exposures to that so we we
move that back to four the other is in
many of the high schools they have what
they refer to as kind of programs of
study so you may have students who you
know pursue kind of a um you know like a
a particular pathway like a stem pathway
or an Arts pathway or Humanity's pathway
and by creating these uh elective
opportunities it allows students to go
deeper in those particular Pathways and
have some more flexibility to do that
whereas if we if we overly prescribe
exactly where those credits are going to
be then it makes it more difficult for a
student to focus on steam or for stem or
focused only on the humanities or
something like that so I think when we
moved it back up to four that was in
response to that kind of feedback that
we received higher education is doing
the same thing uh with with Nei and
taking that degree and maybe knocking it
down to 90
required so I've been highly involved in
a a degree in three program again
because students can go into
postsecondary and get their uh you know
their required classes in three years
and not have uh you know a full year
potentially and depending on the program
of um you know general education
requirements with more work base and
internships different
opportunities okay um just a couple more
things that I wanted to flag for you so
some of the public feedb we got was
relative to the Ed 306 rules around
facilities and uh this is simply because
those rules were completely they were an
exact duplicate between Ed 320 and Ed
306 so the Ed 320 rules are the school
facility rules and so it didn't make
sense to have them in two places the
same exact rule um so now in the 306 we
just ref reference you know the school
facilities pursu to the 320 rules so
that we're not repeating those rules um
and then the other area was relative to
assessment um so we used to have
assessments that were covered in here
but the assessment rules in the 306
previously cover both the requirements
for the state as well as the
requirements for the um uh the local
school district relative to assessment
and so initially we pulled that out and
we had a draft of just assessment rules
that would be required for the school
districts but it included both the
state's requir ments like because we
have certain requirements as an agency
that we have to comply with as well as
the local school districts and uh so
from the public feedback that we got
essentially I think what the board's
going to do is take the school district
assessment requirements put those back
into the 306s so we'll have an
assessment separate assessment rule that
will address the agency's rules relative
to assessment and then we'll put the
school district's rules relative to
assessment into the
306s um and so those are some of the
changes that I was hoping to
flag for you um but I I'm sure that
there probably are other questions as
well that I'm happy to try and respond
to thank you are there now we're getting
into the Q&A uh are there questions from
the
committee and Can I by the way just
point out that this meeting has already
been immensely productive and thank you
well thank you very much well I I'll
start it out um going to the the front
page definitions Y and the reason why is
that a lot of these definitions impact
the back half correct we talked about
competencies or we talked about
performance or achievement um under the
uh definition of acknowledgement of
achievement means when a student has
demonstrated
achievement you know so we're we're
defining achievement as achievement but
it doesn't cut it you know it doesn't
really can you tell me which definition
you're oh not acknowledging that's the
old definition well no I'm looking which
rules am I looking at here
um what do you have for a definition so
the the current rule says
acknowledgement of achievement means
when a student has demonstrated
achievement of District competencies or
graduation competencies that was changed
to achievement of competencies means a
student has demonstrated competencies at
a proficient
level so we tried to eliminate that kind
of circular reasoning in the current
rule would it be proficiency of
competencies uh so we talk about
proficient as a as a term that's defined
so maybe it should be proficiency of
competencies we can take that back and
take a look at that just take a look at
it okay let me go to
Prof you're taking notes right and is
your definition of Competency is the
same as in statute correct and now we I
do know that the board is intending to
just update the competency definition to
mirror statute which is as it should be
okay the definition of work study
practice is next
okay so this uh let me just get to that
so what's interesting on the work study
practice is uh this was a comment that
we got back from the from uh jel car so
we just again there we tried to just
stick with statute because you've
defined work study practices in 193 e2a
6D through F and we just referenced
those it was interesting and we'll have
a conversation with Joker if they want
us to do that we referenced the statute
jel car said well can you write these
out and we're like we just put the
statute in there why would we write them
out but uh so we'll figure out if they
want us to write them out or if we can
just make a reference to the statutory
definition but we've used the definition
in statute right now so they're in 193 e
2- a Roman numeral 6 D through
F the definition for um work study
practices is in 193
H Roman 7
excuse me Roman
8 193 H tell me that again uh Roman 8
H1
definitions now what what's what's your
definition in your proposed can you read
just in what you have there in the side
by side be a good feedback too that
might be another good catch too so we
were using the definition this is why we
needed to re redo these statutes is um
we were using 183 e2a 6
um and we were
referencing uh D through F so D says
applied learning means an educational
approach whereby students have the
opportunity to directly engage in
learning activities using Knowledge and
Skills uh logic means a reasoning skill
that better enables student to analyze
problems in learning areas such as
mathematics and to develop problem
solutions to better understand the
principle um of cause and effect and to
develop critical thinking skills to
better identify fact from unverified
information or data and rhetoric means
the skill of speaking and writing as a
means of communicating or persuasion so
we those that's what you had in statute
and we use those I that's throw back to
193 yeah exactly so that's what we were
using I am concerned about the area
underneath
performance uh accountability for the
work study practices so you're 194 H3
yes H1 oh H1 19 H1 193 H colon one yep r
8 yep targeted sport
Improvement is this work study practices
in my book okay eight got it work stud
practices means those behaviors enhance
the learning achievement I think that
again I think another we should we could
probably put that as the definition I
think that's a good you've got that in
there but you chopped off on page 581
the next page over from and work study
skills that contribute to success in
college career and life that include
communication creativity collaboration
and self-direction no I think that this
should be the definition Rec I think
that's a good we good feedback yeah put
it all in there
yep I don't think any of us saw that
one yeah exactly
[Music]
yes gson luno thank you very much Mr
chair um thank you very much
commissioner which of these um proposed
rules would you excuse me would you say
relate to academic
standards um so that is going to be the
back half generally um other than the
section that we reviewed previously
which listed all of those academic areas
so right right and and when you talk
about and follow up Mr chair yes um when
you talk about this process is being um
and I think I'm using your word
infidelity with the laws what what does
that mean when it when it comes to um to
making changes to uh rules that relate
to academic standards like the ones you
just talked about um so I think that
we're trying to align those content
areas that we referenced there to 193
e2a so okay and would that not sure I
understand the question do my best no
but that's sort of what I was what I was
what I was trying to draw out was was
what you just talked about cuz I think
193 e2a is the operative area when it
comes to uh the these um these minimum
standards and in particular uh e2a and I
think
it's
Roman
4 c um talks about how the state board
and this actually goes back to I think a
question a point you made right at the
top when you said the State Board owns
these rules but it but it says it says
right here in in Roman 4C it reads the
State Board shall not amend any existing
academic standards and shall not approve
any new academic standards without the
prior review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee correct
established in CA which is sort of um
subset of what we've got here today yeah
well so that's the whole that's part of
the reason why we bifurcated this
because then we can the operational
rules can go forward but the those rules
that relate to academic standards and
content standards from 1932a would come
back to the legislature I think that's
the problem that jinny had back in 2014
right okay so so actually that's
something that you didn't really talk
about you talked about how in 2014 um um
those those rules did not uh did not
succeed to go through the process but I
didn't but you didn't really talk about
where they uh where they stopped I
because I was not in I was not here then
so I'm not exactly sure where they got
stopped I just have the you know the
draft of the proposal that had two
versions like one that they proposed and
one that they didn't I don't I didn't
know why it didn't go forward what
happened on that is that 306 Point let's
say 40 and then and and 306 4
One those all were we ran out of time
and there was a two week period there
when we had no rules
and that created problems obviously so
then we reflected back and reopt the
rules that were in law at that time or
Jael C had previously approved that's
where we ended up so all the proposals
went
down so we're going to try to get
something to you that you can be happy
with and work on I don't you know well
there were a lot of areas we were happy
with but we just ran out of time the ru
making process and we do have the
attorneys here from attorney fromel now
so Mr chair this is what I'm going at
it's what you're just talking talking
about here the rulle making process and
and it it it would appear based on the
law that the rulle making process for
any proposed rules that relate to
academic standards has a special process
that involves the um the legislative
oversight committee and and and I guess
the one of the one of the things what
one of the one of my objectives to get
out of out of um this meeting today is
really understand what that process
looks like and what uh what your
anticipated timeline is for that process
so for example if um if rules that
pertain to academic standards have to be
reviewed and recommended by the
oversight um committee when's that going
to H when when's the idea that's going
to you know to happen is that going to
happen on August 14th or is that going
to happen um is it happening right now
um and you know uh and and how would
that process go um and and and I I would
really refer to and I'm sure you've seen
this before commissioner this um this
very overly complicated um uh flow uh
flowchart decision chart with respect to
JL car and I'm being factious when I say
overly complicated because I know it's a
very involved process here in New
Hampshire but for the ACT for stand for
rules that relate to academic standards
it has even some some additional um U
process uh in there involving oversight
so timeline process I'm wondering when
um when we're going to really hear about
um these
things so that process again before I
can even get something to you I have to
get a consensus among the constituents
of uh you know Educators and the Nea and
NH HSA there's no reason for me to bring
you something that is not that we can't
reach consensus as uh as the education
system to even take a look at so um I
know that the board is working on that I
don't know what their timeline is
they're they're actively working on it
um you know is it probably over the
summer sometime I would guess um you
know and again we're going to fit it
into we've also got the 1868 process
again just in conflicts with statutes
which is you know the State Board of
Education shall adopt academic standards
right so I've got that statute that I
have to reconcile with this same process
that I have over here in
193e um but so I mean they're working on
it and but I until I have something that
is cooked enough to bring to you um you
know but I think that I will come to
before anything is final almost like in
this process uh so that you can then
have substantive weighin on it but I
want to bring something to you that's
pretty far no I I appreciate that very
much commissioner because we're not
looking to waste anybody's time waste
your time exactly and and so what what I
what I take that for for for today's
meeting is really an update we're
correct where where we are you talked
about so so today is is how we're in the
middle of the process right
now but I'm going to separate the two
processes because I've got the academic
areas and then I've got the operational
stuff I think the operational stuff
we're okay we're going to just work
through this with the board and be able
to move that process forward in jail car
but relative to the academic stuff as
you point out there's an extra step in
that process
does um and and just one more question
CU you know I think there's I I have a
hard time delineating the the hard the
bright line difference between you know
you know form or process and and uh or
you know mechanical rules versus the
academic standards but in your opinion
where do where do things like class size
um fit in is that like like you know air
quality or is that like um what what uh
what teachers are doing in the classroom
yeah so well I mean so what teachers are
doing in the classroom is probably not
the right vernacular I would use but if
you look in the rules in the existing
rules I think it breaks about 31 uh
you'll see there's a very clear kind of
delineation we started at uh 30631 is
where it starts and we begin with Arts
education programs right so then we
start in with content areas is where we
began to make that shift and hence my
question for you all relative to these
are content areas I think that we only
have authority to deal with areas that
are enumerated in 193 e2a I got family
and consumer science which is not there
but I do have it in here right and so
the question is you know and we'll work
on those and probably bring those to you
and you're going to have to decide you
guys want us to bring these you know
family and consumer science Rules do you
want us like when I bring you a proposal
for those rules like we'll work on them
you got to decide hey Frank you guys
don't have authority to take that
forward because your Authority on these
rules is limited to 193 e2a um but
that's a decision that I think I really
it's a legislative decision what do you
guys want us to do with this right and
and just along this this this whole
string and thank you commissioner I
appreciate your um your your Indulgence
in this in this area but um in in the
same section of law3 e2a dropping down
to Roman 6B
and now we're into the definitions area
that you were just um talking about you
you cited a definition for Applied
learning B is the definition of academic
standards so in that definition and
statute uh academic standards means what
a student should know and be able to do
in a course or at each grade level so
can you reference me where you're
reading I'm not so I'm on page I'm on
page 560 on this book okay and where
which where are you reading uh down at
the
bottom academic standards and it's the
definition yes okay um and so it means
what a student should know and be able
to do in a course or at each grade level
yeah and and I'm wondering does that
does that definition of academic
standards is that definition of academic
standards limited to uh just the the
curriculum um such as what begins on 30
in your rules on 30631 which you say is
the the bright line delineation between
academic standards and or academic
related St rules and and and other rules
um is is the definition of academic
standards in law really a brightline
thing that really talks about that talks
about courses and programs or does what
a student should know and be able to do
in a course or at each grade level
also relate to for instance your your uh
proposed class sizes by grade level or
by learning uh level does it also relate
to that too and and I'm just putting it
out there commissioner because just
because the the the the current
rules front half and back half where the
back half is academic standard starting
on rule 31 for Arts education program
just cuz just cuz the State Board said
it there years ago doesn't necessarily
mean that that academic standards
doesn't relate to other things too just
put so then so what I would tell you is
I don't think that's what the words say
I think the words are pretty clear in
terms of what's being said and as well
that would
contradict um you know the historical
how these rules have been worked on
historically um really
forever uh in terms of the State Board
adopting changes to those front half um
and implementing those for the schools
and then really when they work on the
back half the 31 forward the history has
been that they come to the legislative
oversight committee for the most part
I've found instances where they have not
even come to the legislative oversight
committee for changes there um so I
think that uh you know where the board
has drawn that line is the right
line I think this discussion just
reinforces some of the issues that we'
previously discussed for example in that
same section law there on page 560 when
we're talking about the minimum
standards of public school approval and
then academic standards when we talk
about grade level it's not learning
level yeah I understand and and and and
that's reflected throughout this book so
I thought that was fair input yeah 100%
heard that I think that that that's very
important and I I think what we need to
be looking at in terms of these academic
areas that they were in uh I know this
committee will like to have the
opportunity to look for examp I was
looking at Career Technical education
and I'm seeing some definition changes
there as well from what we have as
definition in the book and if you would
provide that to us if you know there's a
statutary definition we will have
Fidelity to the statutory definition and
we'd like to follow that up with
communication with you I know there's
two of us on the CTE advisory Council
right here on on this particular
committee as well and it's an area which
we see we need to be emphasizing more
than we have in the state and then on
page 561 under the annotated version and
all that there's reference to the
application personal finance literacy
and the intent was that to be not necess
in under studies earlier in law we do
say it may be integrated within other
areas but there is also an intent that
we must teach that stuff now I don't I
I'm up to however you know Local
District wants to do it that's their
decision their choice but in the long
run we need to have some kind of a
measure or accountability that it is
being taught whether it's a separate
course a required course um I I think I
like that the State Board really to
consider that this is an issue that has
been heard over and over and over again
our kids are don't know how to use a
Visa card a Master Card they don't know
how to write a check they don't know how
to file taxes and on it goes so
um so points of interest there
also in the as we call these things like
Arts education I mentioned that should
homogenize that with the statute I think
that's a good idea information and
communication Technologies program to
Computer Sciences what we call it now uh
social studies including the other five
economics civics government history
geography yep um and under technology
engineering education program um we have
an engineering and Technology
there's some changes yeah we can
homogenize those I think that's really
good input
so are there any other questions from
the committee here what we can do is we
can bump our heads together here not
necessarily this morning but uh at a
later date and trying to get some
information to you when would you need
to receive that buy commissioner
um you know in the next I know you're
going through the the process right now
yeah like I mean if you're able to get
us something by the end of the month
that would be wonderful be fine okay we
can do that Mr chair yes thank you I've
got just a a couple of um questions that
I think relate that are update okay
oriented um I've I've heard through just
conversations with other people that um
that that um uh certain individuals who
have been leading this process have
changed over time just wondering um uh
who's sort of handson um leading the uh
uh the development work on these uh on
these Draft rules right now well so I'm
not sure what changes you're referring
to because we have had continuity so I'm
not I'm not sure how I I had just heard
um you know Ju Just from from people
suggesting to me that there had been
changes but but who's who's in fact the
you know sort of Le leading the Hands-On
work well I mean so these now are in the
hands of the State Board of
Education okay okay um
and and
the so the the the the research and
development effort that was contracted
out has been that those deliverables
have been met and now that's with now
this is with the State Board no there is
still ongoing support from the national
Center for Competency Based education
okay there is ongoing support there okay
thank you very
much is there is there anyone from the
Department of Education that works with
the board on any of this there are many
people that do depending upon what the
particular rule is like like
me so do you have qu and if you have
questions you can direct them to me and
that would be helpful thank you I know
I've worked with Steve Appleby I've
worked with Jeff beard it just depends
on the area there's there's all kinds of
areas right so we're calling in the
various
experts um but not you know some of
those individuals don't have domain
knowledge that cuts across many
different areas and then we have
individuals who are have expertise in
the jail car and the r writing process
who are involved in it as well Julie has
joined can you answer this for me please
um when we look at the back half and
we're looking at those curriculum areas
relevant to the the 13 categories and
criteria for an adequate education we
noticed for example when we looked at we
had the number of bills coming to us
this year dealing with mental health of
of students in their schools and we saw
that mental health was one of those
elements listed underneath health and
wellness as those areas been struck
in what I believe you know in the copies
I have here there's all lines going
through all those elements why are we
striking out some of those items which
have our our curriculum Frameworks are
outdated most of them and so we looked
at that and and when we looked at that
we say well we are providing mental
health it's required in the 306s I can't
remember what part was whether was that
36 or whichever one it might have been
right why we why did we strike all that
stuff yeah so I mean there's ongoing
work on the back half of the document
and part of that is because um over time
that back half of the document has um
gotten what I would refer to as somewhat
confused sometimes um and convoluted um
as representative luno pointed out um
you know the the State Board of
Education so you're setting 193e and
you're saying these are the areas of
study uh the State Board of Education is
adopting academic standards in those
various areas um you know whether that's
common core for my mathematics my
English language arts we've got social
study standards we've got Health
standards um and then so and so you have
these standards and then essentially
those standards then are supposed to
translate
into cials that aligns to those
competencies which align to those
standards right that's the dividing line
the state is adopting standards the
local district is responsible for
developing the competencies that align
to those stand standards and the
curriculum for instructing that um what
happens is these academic areas in the
back of this document sometimes come in
conflict with the actual academic
standards that the state board has
adopted and so we had asked and I know
that Educators have been working on
going through that back part of the
document and uh you know kind of the
agreement that we reached with that
group was that they were going to go
through that document and they were
going to identify rules in these areas
so rule language that can be
incorporated into another or new section
of the Ed 306 front half of the draft
specifically where that language should
be incorporated and provided right so
there's stuff in that back area in those
academic areas that's more General
instructional stuff about how you
operate a school well that should be in
the front part right we don't need that
in the academic area it should be in how
you operate a school the next thing
excuse me was uh proposing rule language
that can be carried forward for
consideration for modifying our State
academic standards and content
Frameworks right because there's stuff
in those back half documents that
probably belongs in the state standards
because at the end of the day it's those
State Standards we want our Educators to
be able to go to one place and say like
this is if I'm an Arts educator here's
my Arts standard this is what I'm
supposed to be teaching right not I got
to go to my standards and then I got to
go check the 306s and see if it calls
out something else I'm trying to make a
simplified uh system that has coherence
as it's applied um the next is that
there might be rule language proposed
for Content areas not addressed by
current academic standards right right
so I've got areas in the back half of
that document in those academic areas
that I don't have academic standards for
like we've not adopted State academic
standards for personal finance now most
schools are using the national standards
for that but we've not adopted them so
we're going to need that content in the
back half of that document because I
don't you can't come in conflict with a
standard that hasn't been adopted by the
State Board of Education or it could
just be that it's information that is
Superfluous and it's not really needed
it's not adding to uh you know clar for
our Educators who are trying to instruct
those standards into the schools so that
is kind of the work that we're doing
there yes go ahead so you are
incorporating the feedback that you got
from that group of Educators that was
working together and and gave a lot of
feedback to you into the back half of
the correct we're trying to we're trying
to discern it it was it's not always
that clear because we have a lot of
various opinions right so what we've
seen
is um there was a lot of diversity of
opinion among people in terms of what we
wanted but we're trying to distill it
and we'll make proposals right so
there'll be proposed changes we'll do
side by sides on that as well and kind
of work through
that thank you
yeah the I just would like to close out
the back half here but that discussion
did there when we looked at health
education this year and we looked at the
old curriculum Frameworks which are
ancient
history 2003
2003 and and when we looked at this
there was significant guidance that came
to us from both the old
Frameworks and and from the
306s um we were trying to discern where
are these academic standards now I've
asked that question not just of you but
I've asked of Jenny I've asked of L now
way going way back and I you know and
they say well that the academics the
that the curriculum Frameworks are the
academic standards that's correct well
then we eliminated act the curriculum
Frameworks we had legislation this year
where we put curriculum Frameworks back
into law it's not been signed into law
yet but we hopefully will get that back
into law so then when we see these
curriculum Frameworks which are
guidelines but also host and contain
these academic standards are we going to
be able to look anywhere and clearly see
the academic standards for geography or
for for health or so those are
incorporated into those curriculum
Frameworks and again historically going
back into the early 2000s that is
how the that everybody worked on this
system is that they created what you
could call academic standards but they
weren't solely that they Incorporated
the curriculum Frameworks into it to try
and make the AC my understanding is
anyways to try and make those academic
standards more useful right um for the
Educators so those curriculum Frameworks
were adopted by the State Board of
Education as the academic standards for
those content areas they were voted on
you know decades you know in the various
decades in past you I I I get that but I
also say that you know I as a school
administrative principal for years and
years and years we looked at you know
various sources to tell us what were
what are the standards to be taught at
this level right and we often times at
that time had to go to the old textbooks
we didn't have it or what were the goals
or the objectives yeah and but now where
do we go we go to these academic
standards and we're seeing a progression
of topics that should be taught right
are all those topics the academic
standards or are there some clear
academic standards for civics education
yeah no so those are so for example
those were adopted in 2005 as the by the
State Board of UC ation as the academic
standards and so just going one step
further what what we're trying to do in
this process to your point is not have
two places so I got to reference my you
know curriculum framework academic
standards and I got to reference the
306s to figure out what I'm supposed to
be doing can we get this stuff
Consolidated into a single place um you
know is the direction that I mean that's
really the framework that you all have
set up right and going back to the very
beginning of you know that that the uh
the state is responsible for yeah say
it's a shared responsibility yeah but
right but the state is responsible
public okay um in the system the state
establishes minimum standards for public
school approval the front half and
academic standards for inclusion and
delivery of an educational system right
and so that's what we're trying to say
like that's what we're going to come up
with right and so what we don't want to
do is we don't want those academic
standards to be diffused in two places
so that people are like well I looked
over here but I didn't look over here
like let's see if we can't get all this
stuff together I think is the right way
to do that I I hope you can manage to
get this thing done so we can I'm not as
optimistic I can redo all of those
because you open up these academic
standards and it just goes uh you know
it's very difficult there's a lot of
constituent input that needs to take
place well as a local school district I
have responsibility for curriculum and
instruction yep and when I look at my
curriculum instruction and instruction
has to
parallel what we're how we're what we're
teaching yep and the accountability
system uh so that I want to be able to
look in one place as the school
principal saying here it is uh teachers
in the building that the these are the
academic standards if you can get them
all hooked into those Frameworks that's
wonderful rather than us having to go to
the 306s and carve through that and
trying to figure it out exactly I am
wholeheartedly in agreement and I think
everybody would benefit from a more
straightforward simplified type of an
approach yeah thank you yes represent L
thank you very much thank you again
commissioner um so so I appreciate what
you talked about in terms of the um the
rules being the proposed rules being in
draft form that it's a working document
right now and that uh and that nothing's
really you know you know firmed up in um
you know well I do know that the board
is still working on it yeah that's what
I'm saying that's what I'm saying so I
appreciate uh I appreciate that very
much and and I'm glad to hear it too
because we've got a lot of different
sort of versions uh floating around this
table right here so we're not quite sure
where where where things are at today
and and and so your your updates though
have been very helpful but Mr chair and
and Mr commissioner I would it would it
be would now be the the time though
where where uh the legislature this
committee the legislature the Ed
committee could um could could maybe get
some firm definition as to the process
um step-by-step process moving forward
and uh and a um and and a possible
timeline for these rules give and I'm
just saying a possible one like like you
know you know in the process it takes
six months to do this or it takes three
months to do that uh but uh something
that we could look at now while these
rules are being worked on so that we
understand what all of our different
roles are in the um uh in you know in
the development recommendation and and
approval of of the rules do we know
enough to to to draft a process and
workflow document at this so the the
process that you should follow is the
jail car process right that includes
statutory timelines and statutory uh you
know deadlines for moving forward so we
are going to follow that process and
depending upon you know how much input
we get or don't input we get I don't you
know the State Board is going to take up
this the draft and continue working on
it like until they agree on a final
draft I can't go to the next step
anyways and so they're working on it but
I think your best framework is the jail
car process which is statutory so so
thanks but but as we've talked about for
the academic related standards the quote
back half of this document it also
involves this um um this committee is
isn't that my isn't that the understand
what we got to do is we have to the last
time this was done in
2015 and and that was
the the requirement we have put in law
every 10 years and so we can back off
and we can Calculate working with
attorney moral here and others
determine where what's the final date
you're going to have to get this thing
done by and and working with the board
and finding out where the board is I
think that there's a some latitude for
this and so we can get some dates and we
can start planning ourselves as far as
the communication first I'd like to see
the side by side that you it's a working
document now that's not the final
product we get that but we need to be
able to offer some suggestions at and
I'd like to put a list of those things
together and get that off to you guys as
soon as possible at the end of this
month y so we will meet again for the
end of this month and then we will also
work with the attorneys and and and the
board finding out is there a projected
date in which your your board is going
to take that I the the board is governed
by the jail car process right so I'm
trying to encourage them
in a in AED that comp with their statut
rle Mak requirements right if they
default on that process I'm not sure
what if we have to go back to the
beginning I'm not sure how that works
right
so yeah i' I've not ever defaulted on
the rulemaking process
so the attorney can give us some help
alone that we don't need exactly but he
can lay out the the jard process that we
are bound by right that's what we have
to follow so well
commun clearly for us right okay I think
that needs to be done thank you very are
there any other questions of the
commissioner right now Ju Just a just a
a thought Mr chair um that while while
we while we have I think a little I
think we' sort of budgeted you know you
know couple hours for for this meeting
so uh we we possibly have a little bit
of time for this but we do have some
members for the public here transparency
has been an important you know part of
this process and I'm wondering if maybe
we could um we could open up to uh to
some public comment no I I'm not going
to go there with that because I put it
out clearly beforehand and in the letter
that I communicated with the
commissioner that we are not going to
take other input in fact the hearing
process has been established where the
public can communicate on
these you know Draft rules directly to
the State Board of Education and when's
that process
conclude so we had an as I pointed out
an extended public comment period that
lasted from February 15 till April 30th
um is how long that the public comment
period is we still continue to receive
uh feedback from constituents in the
field and we're happy to take that they
cannot be part of the formal public
comment at this point in time but
certainly I rick gave me a number of
good suggestions today that we will take
back and uh and process those so were
interested in getting a good proposal um
but we did have an extended public
comment period and provided ample
opportunity for everybody to
testify yeah I you know if if we have
desire to get you know individual
members on this committee can go get
that in information then we can have a
meeting we could get input if we want
that on the back half regarding the
academic standards however I think for
us to conduct a hearing on the minimum
standards for public school approval
were stepping out of our domain uh our
responsibility is not that it is that of
the academic standards which are
integrated into the back part but
there's front part too like competencies
impacts the back and the definitions
impact the back and so um but I I feel
this time that we are able to you
know in the letter I wrote the the June
11 meeting is open to the public however
the primary purpose of meeting is to
allow for a dialogue between the
committee members and the department
as as public testimony and written
comments regarding draft changes to the
306 rules has been received by the state
board and I do not want to get into the
role of being the state board and I've
tried to summarize for you kind of where
we are in the process all of the
information all of the public feedback
is on our website everybody can go look
at every single thing all the
correspondents the entire process for
how we've gone through this all the
various iterations are out there as well
um so if people have questions I would
encourage them to take a look at that
are there any further
comments so with that I'm going to close
the meeting and thank you very much
commissioner thank you I wish you uh
good pathway ahead here with this uh
it's it's very very important and it
impacts every student in this state and
future students and um we we have to
make some changes here if we don't do
something it's just like I said the
other day with higher education we gotta
watch what's going to be 10 years from
now and it's not going to be good
thank you thank
you okay um we we are still here um we
had um is there any discussion amongst
ourselves on this I you know I heard
that we're probably going to have to
have another meeting here this month oh
I'm sure thank you um yeah I I I I think
you're probably right Mr chair
um and and something I I I want to think
a little bit more about too and I wonder
you do Mr chair is a comment you just
you just made which I think was very
good that that um um that there are
parts of the front half document related
to the minimum standard such as
competencies that that also have bearing
on the on the academic standards and
should things like competencies um or
changes to
competencies things like that that
relate to the academic standards also be
in the um in the subject to the the
oversight um committee I I think that's
it it's relates to Improvement and
assessment and that's what this
committee's task to do um I think there
is a relationship between some items now
maybe a school facility I've always
advocated though that's the fourth leg
of the stool if you don't have a good
building not going to have you know
things a chemistry lab but I I think
that we should be looking at those
definitions which impact what we're
doing in the second half like Career
Technical education or or or or or
competencies or or proficiency vers
achievement and learning verse grade I
think that interacts with the back half
there's some areas though that don't and
it's not our domain so I think we'll try
to filter through that and and identify
the areas I'm not saying no to it no no
you know thank you thank you very much
Mr chair and and perhaps as the as the
commissioner updating the um the side by
side that um that that maybe for a first
pass you know those those rules that
that do have bearing on academic
standards not just rule 31 on but those
could be indicated in a side by side so
that we we we all know what we're
referencing so so I'll make the easy
reference which I and I apologize for
jumping back in but I sound like you had
a question so it's that list right that
says like for example where it says and
again this is some of the feedback from
jail car which says family consumer
science right are we am I able to make
rules on that or not that's a question
that I have um you know and so if this
you know body can kind of weigh in on
that and say do you want us to do rules
on that um or not we're happy to or
we're happy to not but we want to try
and make sure that we're having Fidelity
to that statute uh uh attorney Merl
moral um did uh representative Maguire
leave a submit a list from jel car or
things for the doe to look at that we
could possibly get a hold of yeah we
have our comments well we have our whole
com we have our whole the jail car
comment we could provide that to you as
well I mean it includes all of your
comments back to us oh yeah we'd like to
have the comment sheet okay we can send
that to as well yeah that'd be
good anything
further I think we're done hopefully get
an early lunch I want to thank the
public for commenting um we're not done
we're just going to work on this uh I
think there's I think there's some good
things going forward but some things
which the we have to look at from uh you
know legislative perspective so thank
you very much all have a good
afternoon
y me yeah you didn't get us out the
other day
12:05
e
e for